non non depuis que je l'ai je prends pas
en téléphone c'est indispensable Mo
c'est c'est assez pratique et vous
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez bah c'est
biene bien vous l'avez non vous aimeriez
l'avir bien sûr non je ne l'ai pas mais
mais pas je travaille là chez mes
patrons ils l'ont et je trouve que c'est
c'est vraiment très bien préfère lire
une belle lettre que d'avoir un coup de
téléphone très bien ça permet de
communiquer à distance sans avoir écrire
une lettre par exemple pu avoir la
réponse tout de suite vous avez besoin
d'un docteur en pleine nuit hein avec
une personne âgée mais trve que c'est
vraiment bien mais enfin quand les
enfants sont malades toi téléphone au
docteur moi je trouve ça rend tellement
service et ça vous évite tellement de la
fatigue pour ça j'aurais bien aimé
l'avoir aussi et je trve que c'est pas
suffisamment répandu en France il n'y a
pas assez de téléphone c'est vrai en ce
qui concerne la densité téléphonique la
France occupe le 16e rang dans le monde